&gt;&gt; Remember that MathQuill is the tool that's allowing us to write many of the
things in this class really beautifully. So, and we want you to enter things
like x to the 4th over 2. It actually looks like this in the spot where you
input things. But as great and powerful as MathQuill is, there are a couple of
little idiosyncratic things that you should know about how to enter things.
Especially when it comes to using parentheses. You may have noticed that if you
type one parentheses, one opening parentheses, that is, in a text box where
MathQuill is being implemented, then the closing parentheses appears as well.
And you'll be typing in this spot in the box in between them. This generally
makes your life much easier. But in certain situations, it can be kind of
tricky. One of these interesting, and potentially troublesome features, is that
once you have a set of parentheses, and then something written inside them, if
you want to delete the parentheses but leave whatever you've written inside,
then you can't have your cursor sitting out here and then press Delete because
that will delete the entire expression. So let's say you'd written 26 m inside
parentheses. If you put your cursor right here and press Delete or Backspace,
everything would disappear. If instead, however, of having the cursor out here
to the right of the entire expression in the parentheses, you put the cursor
just inside of opening parentheses, so just to the right of it. Then, you can
press Delete or Backspace or whatever your computer uses to get rid of things
before the cursor. And that'll leave you with whatever was inside parentheses
originally. I'd like you to get some practice in how this works using this
expression right here. So once it comes time for you to take this quiz, I'd like
you to type in 3 plus open parenthesis 2 x y minus 7 open parenthesis x z, and
then two close parenthesis. And then, in as few keystrokes as possible, change
this to just 3 plus 2 x y minus 7 x z. So, this is just giving you a chance to
figure out how to delete parentheses without deleting expressions that were
inside of them.